[Music]
what is up everybody its Anna Mac and
goes and your boys from anime uproar and
for this video we thought we'd do
something a bit different so for this
video we took a bunch of our friends who
wouldn't really consider themselves
anime fans and we have a wide range some
people really don't know anything about
anime and some people have watched a few
of them but overall these are not anime
fans and we thought what we do was get
them to react to Devilman crybaby one of
the craziest animes we've ever seen and
we thought that would be fun for you
guys so I hope you enjoy and what's up
anime uproar fans my name is Tom and I'm
Joey and we also have a channel called
Hong Plus Julie it makes sense right so
these guys invite us invite us in I
don't know I can't speak this is the
same as on our channel they invited us
to come watch some anime today I'm Mike
I'm Nate
Sailor man say Mike I feel like the only
anime I watch was Dragon Ball Z if that
is even classify this anime and then the
last one I watch was like reboot ninja
scroll a little bit cartoons oh yeah
watch a lot of Pokemon that's a lot of
pokemon gold right but I know like
things can get hard more like sexual
like gory and all that stuff but like
I've never watched any of that like I
never got into it so this is anime
mostly just Japanese
it's the title of it seems a little
we're yeah makes me wanna dance you know
this reminds me of gargoyles it's very
evil
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
was the gym teacher
it looks like the you ever seen Malcolm
in the Middle
yeah pocket I can't breathe what's that
guy's face rent keep angry Oh
[Music]
oh gee how did you not see that guy
there every time I watch a cartoon or
something animated I feel like it's for
kids yeah I'm like okay geez
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
did you just drink gasoline geez
wet man double the whole big drunken
party here we go it's not for kids
who's gonna put that disclaimer out
there right now just because it's a
cartoon it's not for good cartoon that's
are there clubs like this in Japan
mixture
geez this is a very what is the word
graphic okay Rio I think I think Rio is
actually the double out of control this
guy's possessed and he's wearing white
oh no this guy's getting beat up great
see that's why you got to watch who you
hang out with she's just pissed her what
the nipple turned into a shark door
earth water or something we'll just
turned into a Pokemon
oh my god who would go to this Oh bro oh
my
just like Sailor Moon
why would he wear white what crack
tentative teeth how did someone's mind
come up with this what
that time is a strong enough yeah I
think so
well--that's Akira ultimate they're so
cute and innocent boys The Little
Mermaid Man now isn't double-prime a B
okay
I thought it was gonna be like a cute
show the first came out is they all
these dresses they're really cute
then all suddenly it started getting
like I don't know no it started with
like the close-ups like the boobs right
now that's pretty dark not what I was
expecting
scary scary oh yeah this might sound
stupid but I thought I was laying more
for kids yeah it's like an animation so
I thought it was like more innocent and
then I was like no this is travel I was
thinking like Dragon Boat I was thinking
about that cute Japanese culture younger
yeah there's some sex into that my enemy
is all about big boobs and butt shots no
there's always extreme animes there's
always gonna be some you like and
somebody don't ya I watch them like I've
seen you guys walk some stuff that's
weird I feel like I want to see what
happens
yeah but I'm like scared
are going to like the cosplay babe if
that's all the episode one what else is
there you know yeah I feel like it's
gonna get so much more dark interesting
totally like something different than
what we've ever watched before yeah yeah
no I have to I don't know like I don't
have this this I need to know what's
happening I'm definitely I'm watching
episode 2 yeah I want to see if I miss
something well if you watch it all that
you it yeah and that's it for this video
guys really hope you enjoyed it if you
did like it make sure to smash that like
button and subscribe for more
let us know in the comments if you have
a specific one that you'd like us to do
yeah if you want to see more videos like
this let us know in the comments also on
social media Twitter and Instagram at
anime uproar and until next time see ya
space cowboys
[Music]
you